carl filled up the tank of his truck
with 400 liters of fuel and set out to
deliver a shipment of bananas to alaska
the truck consumed 0.8 liters of fuel or
eight tenths of a liter of fuel for each
kilometer driven graph the amount of
fuel remaining in the truck's tank in
liters as a function of distance driven
in kilometers and all right over here we
have we have a graph where we have a
coordinate plane where our horizontal
coordinate is distance in kilometers and
our vertical
our vertical axis is fuel in liters
so and we can move we can define the
line by moving these two points around
because two points define a line
and so let's just think about two points
that we could figure out can we figure
out the fuel at two different distances
and then that will help us define the
line
well the first thing that we might want
to think about is well what what about
before we've traveled at all that might
be an easy thing to figure out what was
the amount of fuel in the tank when we
haven't traveled at all and that they
tell us that in in this passage and i
encourage you to pause the video and
think about that
well they tell us carl filled up the
tank of his truck with 400 liters of
fuel and then set out to deliver a
shipment of bananas so before he had
driven it all right after he had filled
his tank he had 400 liters of fuel so we
could say when distance was zero
kilometers he had 400 liters of fuel so
we have one point on that line now we've
got to think about where we might want
to put where we want to put this other
point and the way i think about it is
well let's just we know he's consuming
he's consuming eight tenths of a liter
of fuel for each kilometer driven but
they don't have you know we're not going
by one kilometer two kilometers they're
going by this is like 50 kilometers 100
kilometers so let's think about how much
fuel he would have consumed after
driving 100 kilometers and if he
consumed that much we would subtract
that from the amount of fuel he started
with and then that would tell us that
would tell us where this point would be
it's going to be someplace over here and
it's going to be it's going to be below
400 because we're consuming fuel fuel
should be going down as distance
increases this should be a downward
sloping line
so i have my i have my scratch pad here
let me let me get it out
and i have the same question there just
gives us all the same information but
what i want to figure out is
so we already know
we already know that
so we have distance
distance
let me i'll just write
actually let me just write the whole
thing give myself a little bit more
space
distance in kilometers
distance in kilometers and then you have
fuel
you have fuel in liters
you have fuel in liters and we already
figured out that before he got on right
after he filled up his tank but before
he
set out on his trip
at distance zero kilometers he had 400
liters of fuel and we've already
actually plotted that
but then we said well what happens at
100 kilometers at 100 kilometers how
much fuel will he have
well they tell us that he consumes
0.8 liters of fuel for each kilometer
so 0.8
liters
per kilometer and then we just multiply
that times the number of kilometers so
times
100 kilometers
the units work out kilometers divided by
kilometers we're just going to be left
with liters and then we multiply the
numbers eight tenths of a hundred well
that's going to be equal to 80 and the
units are liters
80 liters so the distance of 100
kilometers he's going to have consumed
right let me be careful here he's going
to have consumed 80 liters he's going to
have consumed 80 liters so the fuel
the fuel is actually going to be
what he started with what he started
with
minus how much he consumed so it's going
to be minus
0.8 and if we want to write the units
there i might as well so you know this
is
liters right over here this is 400
liters and i can write this kilometers
kilometers it's going to be 400 liters
minus
0.8
liters
per kilometer
times
times we've got clear times
100
times 100 kilometers
and same thing kilometers divided by
kilometers and we are left with 400
liters minus 0.8 liters times 100 well
that's just going to be equal to
400 liters which is how much he started
with
minus eight tenths of a hundred is 80
and the unit's left is 80 liters so 400
liters minus 80 liters that's going to
be 320 liters
so when he has traveled 100 kilometers
he will have 320 liters left in his tank
so let's plot that so when he has
traveled 100 kilometers actually i just
randomly had put the point there he is
going to have 320 liters left in his
tank and just like that we have plotted
the line that shows how much fuel he has
in his tank as a function of as a
function of distance traveled and you
can even see from this that he's going
to run out of fuel at the 500 kilometer
mark